the Joe Rogan experience was there
someone that you met when you first met
him with your like I can't even believe
that I'm sitting there with a van der
Holyfield or someone like that someone
real famous where you couldn't believe
you were actually being around them
I don't have to say Roy don't like
John's cuz I never was like a big fan
boy I will always be like God man he
just humans like me but when I seen Roy
for the first time I was like Paul
that's Roy Jones jr. like I met Floyd
Mayweather but this boy Jones jr. like
yeah it was just crazy
he was real cool and you know I was just
like damn I didn't want to be like aw
like tries to out like down like I met
Sugar Ray Leonard when I was an amateur
and it didn't feel the same
it was just like man that sugar because
this is a different era
because it was a you didn't watch him
fight watching Roy Jones man when I was
a kid when he was in his prime he would
lead with a left hook he's like more
than a jab he would just whip that left
hook at dudes and they didn't know what
the [ __ ] to do with that that speed was
preposterous so fast whoa Roy was doing
stuff to people that made you just go
wow like he's not even doing the same
thing they're doing right he's like he's
on another dimension he's a different
record speed you know he was so fast
like Max Kellerman had this incredible
rant once about just realizing how good
Ward Jones was in his prime this wasn't
like he wasn't around great fighters but
they couldn't do [ __ ] to him he was
around world champions but he was
lighting them on fire right it was crazy
and you know all good things come to an
end it only lasted for you know X amount
of years I mean what was the best years
of his Championship reign but he was
untouchable untouchable untouchable
wooden knocked out Virgil Hill with that
body shot Wow
you know like god damn one punch when he
when he put his hands behind his back
and still knocked out James Turner I
mean he couldn't drop his hands like
this and James Toney does it too many
leaps in the drop some with that one
dude he knocked out with his hands
behind his back who was that dude was on
the ropes
yeah put his hands behind his back the
dude moves forward and drops but not
- mouth like this is a movie scene right
this is a real life no one does that in
real life right Joyce was having fun
with people yeah he was having fun with
he was entertaining he was incredible
how fast he was like I didn't man I
didn't met people like Roy he's a fan of
me it's amazing and it's like - like
I'll be like so starstruck it's like man
I'm a fan of you and he's a fan of you
you a fan of me like today today is so
happy I was on Instagram and I was like
I went out past LL Cool J because we was
listening to some old school music and
I'm like ding ello got a Instagram so I
clicked on them and he's following me I
said Bo look LL Cool J following me on
instagram is crazy just the think of all
the people that you like grew up
admiring and like you a fan of and for
you to see them fan of you it's like
damn like a high person I met Iverson
Wow and he came up to me and he was more
happy to see me then I was him Jairus
Crawford oh man Wow and I was like I was
a sinner looking at him like this hour I
was seeing all those you know
celebrities and all-time greats that's
big fans of mine and it's like [ __ ] does
it wear off or do you still freak out I
still freak out
I still freak out sometimes like it just
depends on the person like [ __ ] like
damn right
like Snoop or something like that like
Snoop - I know I'm a snob like damn like
[ __ ] that's when you know that you made
it to a certain level and you know
you're a professional sports that
everybody watching you yeah well you
know that's one more thing that's
beautiful about you meeting those little
kids is that they can realize like Oh
Terrance Crawford's a man right
he's a man I mean he's a superstar and
he
champion and I see him on TV but he's a
man he's right here he got me in a
headlock right
oh sure we're playing together he's a
nice guy oh he's a person yeah because
you see someone that's achieved a
certain level of status and Championship
reign and you know see him on TV
knocking people out that doesn't even
seem like a real person when you're a
kid I that can't be a real person right
and then you're there I think you
shaking his hand he's like what the [ __ ]
this is crazy change that kid's world
yeah like his idea of what the future is
idea what a person is a person is
Terrance Crawford's a person right I'm a
person too I got just got to work hard
and it's crazy because like a lot of a
lot of people they see me and they be
like we are your bodyguards we're
entourage like baby they be having
questions that yeah and I just be like
nah man I'm a regular person they'd be
like me why you don't be on TV like
Floyd Mayweather like man ain't for me
man
I'm chill they be like aw well where are
your cars like they've actually all
kinds of crazy stuff
[Applause]